good day and welcome to nature's returns
a webinar speaker series hosted by the
Yale Center for business and the
environment my name is Andrew woo and I
will be your host for today's webinar
titled valuing nature models of
ecosystem valuation in environmental
policy the Yale Center for business and
the environment is pleased to continue
nature's returns a webinar series that
addresses the growing importance of
ecosystem service valuation and
investment each presentation is recorded
and available on the Yale iTunes U
channel we are pleased to have Katie
Arkema with us today KD arkema is a
senior scientist at the natural capital
project a partnership between Stanford
University the University of Minnesota
World Wildlife Fund and the Nature
Conservancy Katie leaves several efforts
around the world to develop and applied
science regarding nature's benefits to
inform the management of coastal and
marine ecosystems in collaboration with
a belizean government she led a science
team to support the design of a coastal
zone management plan to balance multiple
uses conserved habitats and sustain
human well-being today Arkema will delve
into the models used in the natural
capital project examining the approaches
and research underlying model results
using the case study of belize's coastal
zone management plan argument a low
potential app ecosystem valuation in
guiding policy furthering conservation
while maintaining human wellbeing before
we begin the presentation we would like
to remind our listeners that questions
are welcomed and will be directed to our
speaker at the conclusion of the talk
you can type questions directly into the
gotomeeting chat window and with that we
welcome Katie Arkema to nature's returns
thank you very much Andrew and thanks
everyone for joining me this morning for
me here in Seattle and afternoon for
others elsewhere as Andrew said I'm
going to talk to you today about some
work that I've been doing with my
colleagues at the natural capital
project and the government of Belize
using ecosystem services to inform
coastal zone management there and I'll
start by giving a real brief overview of
and kind of brief context for our work
I'm not going to delve too much into
what we do at NAT cap which is what we
call ourselves for short because I hear
that Gretchen has given a recent seminar
in the series so I'm going to actually
try to get into some more of the details
and this talk today the as we're well
aware humans have a large footprint and
a large impact across our planet and the
sort of ranges from impacts and in
forests and on land to aquaculture in
coastal waters to potential disastrous
events like the Deepwater Horizon oil
spill and so quite frequently the
traditional view of sort of the
relationships between people in the
environment is that people have negative
impacts on on nature and on ecological
resources but recently there's kind of
been a shift in this thinking and that
was really laid out poignant Lee by
Heather Tallis in a paper in Nature late
last fall called an inclusive
conservation and in it she really says
there's space and are thinking about
conservation for not only considering
these sort of top-down negative impacts
of people in the environment but also
how the environment supports people and
then how our influence on on ecosystems
and ecosystem processes can influence
the benefits that environment provides
to people in their space for that work
in conservation science and conservation
practice and it's this sort of
conceptual model that underlies the goal
and the overall mission of the natural
capital project which is to improve
outcomes for people in the environment
on which they depend that's what I've
been kind of broadly working on with my
colleagues through this sort of theory
of change and we have three different
types of work that we do the first is to
develop an apply credible ecosystem
service approaches science and law
tools to support decision makers with
dual development and conservation goals
to learn what works to train users and
disseminate useful approaches and
lessons and to create an informed
community of leaders and practitioners
that will enable large scale policy
changes I'm going to really focus on the
first two today I'm going to talk about
some models that we've developed for
yuko system services and coastal and
marine environments and then talk about
how we use these within and
on-the-ground planning process and
Belize to figure out what works to build
capacity and to sort of further
disseminate the approaches and lessons
from that project before I dive into you
Belize um which is right there and
underneath the star on this map I just
wanted to give all of you a sense of the
wide breadth of projects and places that
net cap is working in and we work
closely with partners on the ground in
all of these locations so whether it's
our partner NGOs like the Nature
Conservancy World Wildlife Fund or local
NGOs there's many of them in Belize that
we worked with or local state or
national governments and the kind of
sort of decision contexts in which we
are incorporating ecosystem services
also span the gamut and those are listed
in the colors and the boxes box below so
from informing spatial planning so where
to site different activities to payments
for ecosystem services especially
related to to watershed planning and
water funds done work in climate
adaptation using sort of green
infrastructure and coastal ecosystems
and in planning for for climate
adaptation and development impacts and
permitting so that has to do with where
do we cite or sorry where do we permit
different activities and how can we use
ecosystem services to not to not only
sort of understand the potential impacts
of permitting certain activities but
also to understand how we can actually
create sort of a long-term sustainable
environment for
important infrastructure frustration
planning and coastal corporate risk
management and this dslite is even a
little bit dated now there's more
projects in more locations and this this
this sort of accounting of all these
different projects and and amassing of
lessons learned from them we've
published in a paper and ecological
economics that should be coming out this
year so diving into Belize one of the
things that I like most about working
with an organization like knack have
that kind of straddles both academic and
basic science and very applied research
is that you get to sort of come up with
new research questions based on
conversations with decision-makers and
with policymakers with stakeholders who
are really trying to figure out how do
we tackle these challenging development
and conservation and management issues
and so within the sort of broad context
of spatial planning and coastal and
marine ecosystems one of the questions
that we hear most frequently and that we
really articulated in our work in Belize
was where should we say coastal and
ocean uses to reduce risk to marine
ecosystems and enhance the benefits they
provide to people and one of another
thing that I really love about working
at NAT cap is that are our projects in
our research really are co-developed
with local partners so that's this this
logo right here is for the Belize
Coastal Zone Management Authority and
Institute and you can find out more
about the work that I'm going to talk
about today hopefully in a paper that is
in review right now in the Proceedings
of the National Academy of Sciences
called improving the margins modeling
ecosystem services leads to better
coastal plans and then my colleague
shantal Clark who is the director of the
Coastal Zone Management Authority and
Institute and the lead on the management
plan for Belize and the status of this
management plan is you can
they see it as open to the public it's
been reviewed broadly by the public so
we can find it you can find it online
book friendly it is been gone through
internal review I'm the national
government there and we'll be hopefully
moving on to the cabinet soon so just to
orient you Belize is a country in
Central America that sits just south of
Mexico and next to Guatemala and
Honduras it's about the land area and
length of coastline of New Jersey which
i think is funny because it's a
completely different kind of environment
but it really is shaped somewhat
similarly it's famous for its blue holes
in the Mayan temples and I think is
really kind of making a place for itself
certainly within the Mesoamerican Reef
but I would say even globally as being
progressive in its planning for
sustainability of Natural Resources
we've had a lot of people interested in
all over the world even from sort of
historically you know very advanced
countries like Australia with their
management of the Great Barrier Reef
have traveled to Belize and and come to
meetings with us and not cap around some
of the work that I'm going to talk with
you about today so the please coastal
and marine environments there's a whole
variety of different habitats from
mangroves to coral reefs to sea grasses
other coastal littoral forests these
provide a numerous benefits to people
from fisheries to tourism to protection
from coastal hazards there's also lots
of other activities that are sort of
pressing for space in this area there's
dredging to support coastal development
coastal development is really important
for for tourism which is one of the
bases one of the sort of main parts of
the economy and there's pressure from
oil and gas industry to explore the
coastal region of Belize for extraction
back in the late 1990s the police sort
of set out this visionary Coastal Zone
Management Act that called for the
facilitated balanced and sustainable use
of coastal and marine environment for
the benefit of lesions in the global
community and one of the reasons it was
really visionary is that it called for
an ecosystem based management which was
really just sort of gaining traction at
that time it's sort of a well-known
phrase now but that was something that
was still kind of being articulated in
the 90s called for combining science and
local knowledge to develop a
comprehensive plan and it called for
spatially explicit information about
where different activities could occur
in order to support sort of key aspects
of the economy that would support
livelihoods and so it wasn't so this was
back in the sort of late in 1990s and
there was kind of fits of starts fits
and starts in terms of the planning
process where different coastal advisory
groups would make lots of headway and
then there would be sort of limited
capacity or our funding would be lost
and back in about twenty ten we were at
nadcap were approached by one of our
colleagues from a small NGO melese
called healthy reefs and she had done
some work with WWF and she felt like
there was a sort of policy window of
opportunity to work with some of the
leaders in the government to sort of
make a push to design this Coast
integrated coastal zone management plan
and so we kind of followed the call in
that coastal act calling for local
knowledge and science to inform planning
so this project involved lots of
stakeholder engagement that was led by
the Planning Department in the Coastal
Zone Management Authority in Institute
and Vietnam capped cotton a cap used our
ecosystem service models that can be and
found within the in
suite of models to quantify and map
several different services in the
coastal and marine areas of Belize you
can see pictured on the right here a map
of Belize with the 9 planning regions
and their coastal advisory committees
that had been formed for these nine
different planning regions and the goal
of the of the plan was to be national
and scope to recognize the ecological
and social differences between these
planning regions so one of the sort of
main challenges of this of this project
and one of the things we had started on
right away that really can really drew
on stakeholder engagement was to develop
future zoning schemes and so these were
based on current maps of uses other sort
of existing and ongoing planning efforts
and stakeholder visions and so we
identified a suite of different
activities that would be important to
give guidance about recommendations on
in a spatially explicit way in the
management plan and can see that was
listed on the right there this slide and
then we developed three different
scenarios conservation scenario that
presented a vision of long-term
ecosystem health through sustainable use
and investment conservation an informed
management scenario that blended strong
conservation goals with current and
future needs for coastal development and
marine uses and a development sort of
oriented scenario that prioritized
immediate development needs over
long-term sustainable use and future
benefits from nature and it is the
informed management scenario that the
government of Belize decided to put
forward in the integrated coastal zone
management plan but the scenario that
they put forward as the informed
management sort of scheme actually
didn't start out that way initially we
sort of designed this middle-of-the-road
scenario that we sort of called the
compromise scenario for a while and then
what I'll tell you about today is
actually how that
sort of central scenario evolved over
time using both stakeholder feedback and
visions for the future but also our
ecosystem service models to improve the
location of these different activities
so with that I'll continue forward
through stakeholder engagement we also
identified sort of four objectives and
three of these are you get some service
objectives so fisheries storm protection
recreation and tourism and then they
also wanted to know about the ecosystems
that underlie those services both for
the support of those services but also
because coral reefs mangrove forests and
seagrass beds are kind of in a way part
of just the sort of cultural fabric of a
lot of these coastal communities so they
wanted to know about these ecosystems in
and of themselves as well as the
benefits they provide to nature sorry I
provide to people so I just wanted to
get start to get under the hood a little
bit and give you a sense of the
consortin sexual model that we began to
develop in this work and that's that we
were thinking about how do these
different zoning schemes which
essentially say where are we going to do
certain things how do how might they
influence the risk to these three
different ecosystems that we have
identified as as important and how then
would the risk to these ecosystems
influence the changes in the magnitude
and and value of these three services in
the future and we imagined iterating
through this model using sort of
feedback from stakeholders local experts
and government officials and essentially
revising that zoning scheme so if you
imagine the sort of development map and
then how did we look at this risk to
habitats well we used a really classic
risk assessment approach that
mine's information about the exposure of
these different ecosystems to different
activities the consequence of that
exposure and then uses use that
information to estimate risk as the
distance from the euclidean distance in
this sort of classic risk plot and then
you sort of can take this information
and map those values of risk in space
and I realize the slide is a little bit
dated so there's a paper on this that's
out in the Environmental Research
Letters then I'm a lead author on but
it's based on a lot of other work that's
been done both in the US by Sam tamari
and 11 and also in Australia there's
lots of other papers on fisheries
specifically fisheries risk assessment
and we sort of applied it and develop
some new criteria for habitat risk
assessment and it's a it's a relatively
simple framework but the reason that
it's really important is because it
allows us to combine the cumulative
effects of a whole suite of different
activities and that's important when
you're dealing with this sort of spatial
management to have a transparent
approach through which we can really
tell what the potential effects are of
each of these different activities to
these different habitats that may have
species species specific responses so we
can use that to develop a map that shows
us where risks risk to all these
different habitats is high medium and
low if you want to categorize it there's
also the outputs of this model come and
just continuous units as well and then
we can use that and feed it into our
service models so just as an example of
the three models the spiny lobster catch
and revenue model uses these kinds of
inputs and outputs we need to know how
much habitat and where and these
habitats are
burn for supporting both the adult and
juvenile phases of spiny lobster
information about the life history the
survivorship growth and recruitment of
the species in this fishery we need to
know information about the fishing zones
where are people going to catch Lobster
and then also the pressure so how much
are people catching and when an
information say for example about the
closures so in Belize there's a temple
closure for for lobster so all of that
gets incorporated into the model kinds
of outputs are catch so a biophysical
unit then also an economic metric the
market value and then we can also use
this approach to get at the value of the
supporting habitats for for the catch of
the lobster so for this my kneecap a
lobster model we use a typical age
structured matrix model with eight
different age classes I just have three
pictured here AB everton Holt
recruitment for those of you that are
familiar with sort of Fisheries and
ecological population models and this
habitat dependent survivorship so
seagrass and mangroves as well are also
really important at the early life
stages and influence survivorship of
recruitment and survivorship of
juveniles and then for the adult stage
coral is important component of
determining survivorship and then all of
that gets put into the model along with
its information that i was mentioning
about Cesar and seasonal closures and
also there's new managed access programs
in Belize so the model can account for
those as well and then these are the
kinds of outputs that through our
discussions with the planning department
in Belize they thought would be most
useful for people to look at and so
they're a map so these the area I'm
sorry max of the catch and we also have
them for value of loves during each one
of the planning regions
and then these maps are a couple these
in the final draft of the plan with
information for each planning region for
the four different scenarios so um you
can see on this figure here on the right
the value of the lobster is on the on
the x-axis both in the economic and in
the biophysical unit and on the y-axis
are the planning regions and yellow is
the current scenario in green as the
conservation blue is the informed
management and development is the black
and what we see is that the catch and
the value of spiny lobster differs
between these different scenarios and it
also difference between the different
planning regions so we began to kind of
get a pictures we were doing this work
of almost which regions are specializing
in different services and I'll come back
to that that concept later on what we
see with the lobster service is that
conservation always does always does the
best across all the different planning
regions that largely has to do with
conservation is where we have the least
destruction of the three habitats that
support survivorship of the different
life stages of spiny lobster and so
lobster was actually one of the more
simple results and I'll continue through
the other ones to give you a little bit
of a more sense of kind of the nuance of
of this analysis so we also looked at
recreation and tourism and storm
protection and this the coastal
protection or storm protection model
involves a lot of really involves the
sort of is an intersection between these
three different disciplines of coastal
engineering ecology and economics and so
underlying the model are sort of a lot
of kind of classic coastal engineering
equations
that we adjusted and sort of advanced to
incorporate the influence of the three
different habitat types and the model is
a one dimensional model that runs along
a crash or transect from offshore to
ensure and essentially it's a wave of
elution model that incorporates the
bathymetric so sort of the change in
Basim 'try caused by a reef as well as
the ragatha t of that reef the density
and spread of seagrass and then the the
density and I sort of buffer width of
mangroves and then we can produce lots
of different metrics and these are these
are just sort of a sense of what's of
what's going on here for just mangroves
so you can see in the bottom graph here
that shows your depth and a simplistic
profile here of depth and in green is
your your sort of width of mangrove
starting at zero which is where your
short line is and then we can the model
allows us to produce output outputs for
waves so that's your top graph there you
can see in the green dotted line that
when you have mangroves intact you have
a reduction in wave height and the next
figure down is essentially your water
level and that's really important both
for estimating erosion but also for
flooding so you have a reduction in
water height where you have your ear
mangroves and then scour as I'm sort of
a metric that we can use to estimate
potential erosion and so we can what we
did is we then coupled some of these
biophysical outputs and metrics with
with evaluation approaches so if you
imagine that you have your coastline
here and if you have no no vegetation so
we can run the model where we
essentially remove the mangroves then we
can estimate what that area of potential
scour the area of Scour or potential
erosion would be then we can compare it
using the model
to with the product both the presence of
vegetation and then we can combine this
with lots of different approaches you
can use property if we have property
values we can look at property damages
if we have an understanding of spatial
distribution of people and populations
along the landscape we can look at
number of people voted people displaced
and also look at roville avoided
renourishment costs and in belize um you
know it was it was challenging to get
some of the deities data but one that we
were able to collect was on property
values and we could look at it developed
reverses undeveloped property values in
all of our different planning regions so
the coastal protection model takes into
account both the sort of biophysical and
coastal engineering kind of forcing
conditions it also takes into account
spatial variation in property values and
whether or not you have developed or
undeveloped land so these are the kinds
of outputs that we produce for coastal
protection and it's interesting is one
of the things that jumps out for coastal
protection is that if informed
management scenarios can almost
consistently higher it across all of the
planning regions and in many places
development actually from development
scenario actually produces greater
returns in the current or the
conservation and this is why it's
important to produce both biophysical
and economic metrics when you're doing
these kinds of analyses to inform
planning because part of what drives
these these differences is that economic
side of your equation so developed land
tends to be a higher value and so the
informed management scenario is almost
like this sweet spot where we have both
conservation of ecosystems but also some
development so that the coastal land is
of a higher value at which then makes
the coastal protection services of these
ecosystems of
higher value okay now moving on to our
last service for tourism looking at
tourism and Recreation Services is
something that's always been very
challenging to do a kind of in a general
way because we've lacked information
about where people go across a landscape
so a lot of times government no tourism
boards will collect information about
sort of tourist activities when people
enter or leave a country but it's really
hard times really hard to know where
they're going when when they're within
the country and it's important to
understand where they're going if we're
going to try to estimate the sort of
role of ecosystems in supporting tourism
and that's because tourism like coastal
protection related services is really a
combination of both the the quality and
the sort of distribution of healthy
habitats its support tourism but also
infrastructure that allows tourists to
access a place and so my colleague
Spencer would developed sort of a novel
or came up with this novel source of
data for tracking people and that's
flickr photos and he's looked at over
the relationship between photo user days
and MP and sort of empirical data about
visitation for different locations where
he's had these data so these are ranged
from like mountains and hiking in Nepal
to UM to marine protected areas and the
Caribbean to even one of the ones I find
kind of funny is even amusement parks
that he's had data for and so we can
look at how this relationship between
photos that people are taking and where
people are going and then we're able to
use this as the response variable in our
tourism model and what we can do is we
can look at with sort of a simple
regression analysis where people going
in relation to our maps of habitats like
corals mangroves and seagrass is
where they going in relation to the maps
that we have of where activities are
occurring coastal development dredging
aquaculture fisheries and so we can
develop a statistical relationship
between sort of visitation and between
these different uses and habitats in the
environment and then we can apply that
to our future scenarios so we can
produce these sort of same kinds of
results where we have a map of where
people are going and expenditures and
then also results by planning region and
what we what we do is we we are able
from the model to get an estimate of the
fraction or the percentage of visitors
that go to each one of these hexagons on
the map and then we can combine that
with data from the bullies Tourism Board
that tells us about the total numbers of
people coming into the country and so
that's how we estimate total numbers of
people and then we can multiply that by
current and future expenditures
estimated by the Belize Tourism Board so
again what we see is it generally the
informed management scenario predicts
higher visitation and expenditures than
the other scenarios also largely because
we find tend to find this sort of best
returns when you have a combination of
conservation and development or you're
creating more infrastructure for people
to access and access these regions but
doing it in such a way that you're not
compromising the sustainability of the
ecosystems um and then one of the things
that we found most sort of useful to
communicate these results it's kind of
having this dashboard where we summarize
across the different scenarios on the
x-axis and the different services on the
y-axis and also including the sort of
functional habitat which is an output of
that risk assessment model
and what we see is that the informed
that we get higher returns of tourism
and coastal protection of the informed
management scenario the highest returns
for a lobster under the conservation
scenario but at least the informed
management scenario is higher than the
current scenario was so we do have
improved returns for lobster relative to
the current scenario and the reason the
sort of approach and analysis is as
powerful as is not just the models it's
because we really tried to look at
multiple objectives from the start of
the process and we were able to combine
the science with stakeholder preferences
and also that this preferred plan
improved services relative to the
current and conservation or development
scenario I'm going to tell you a little
bit more about how we did that so as I
mentioned earlier we began to see that
regions are essentially specializing in
different services and habitats so we
can use this kind of pie diagrams to
look at of our nine planning regions for
example say the southern region where
placencia has located down on this
bottom row of the graph so 8 is one that
sort of really specializes in coastal
protection with all of its extensive
mangrove forests and coral reefs and
that's something that really came out of
our discussions with stakeholders there
as well they're very conscientious about
not necessarily wanting a lot of further
development that could you agree their
their ecosystems central region where
there's a lot of activities in around
Belize City you can really see there's a
lot going on both for habitats and for
services they're so tight I'm kind of
trying to get a sense of what regions
are specializing keeping in mind that
that there is sort of understanding what
kind of sort of analyses are going into
these pie charts so for example key
Cocker number three there on the top row
it's really important for for tourism
and so even though it has
the reason it has quite small pie sort
of fracas there is because it's a it's a
small it's a small planning region so
it's that number three that's really
tiny there so this is sort of just one
example of the kinds of outputs but we
also looked at these on a per area of
aces there's a lot of analysis that goes
on underneath this and so we use this
kind of idea of specializing as well as
our our models to improve that informed
management scenario so if you think back
to earlier on in the presentation I said
originally this scenario we called the
middle of the road of the compromise
scenario and the firt and the original
version of that was really a blend of
just the conservation and the
development scenarios designed by
stakeholders what we did is when we did
our ecosystem service analysis for that
first round of the scenario we found
that it really didn't improve services
much more than the development scenario
so what we did is we identified where
services were particularly low so for
example on in that first iteration of
2012 in August the central region had a
very low delivery of services and we
identify that one of the reasons for
that was because we'd our risk plots
were showing that risk to mangroves
provided a lot of these services was
really high and so we were able to use
this to risk approach of combining
exposure and consequence to understand
where could management have an influence
by reducing exposure of mangroves to
these activities to identify three oil
and gas exploration aquaculture and
dredging that might have a large sort of
influence on risk through that exposure
end of things which we could adjust by
relocating dredging or reducing it
aquaculture and an oil exploration in
that area so then what we essentially
did was we shifted our locations of
these different activities we created a
new map of where different things were
going to be located and that was our
November 2012 scenario
and that began to improve our returns
dramatically but we needed to send that
map out to a public review and we got a
lot of feedback from different
stakeholder groups and from experts and
there were some new policies that had
changed things and so we incorporated
all that into our final version of the
scenario which is our august 2013
version and that was the final informed
management scenario so it's really the
sort of using this iterative approach
between gathering stakeholder
information information from existing
policies and various sort of ministries
that are all have a stake in this this
plan and iterating it with the models
and so through this working believes we
really realized that we kind of have
this approach of we start with this kind
of first step of defining our
partnerships and scoping those both
management and science questions
identifying our objectives and our roles
that helps us understand what kind of
data we needed compile and it's really
important not to go out there and just
gather all the data you can get because
you can go down that rabbit hole forever
so kind of understanding what scenarios
you want to design what you're trying to
questions you're trying to ask also the
models that you're using and helped
inform and constrain that data
collection step um using those models
and then synthesizing the results so
kind of figuring out what sort of
figures and graphics are going to be
helpful for communicating results and
talking about results linking service
outputs with other data like I was
mentioning for the tourism model
understanding what data are available
from the Belize tourism boards so that
we could depict those outputs in terms
of numbers of people and expenditures so
that kind of synthesis and then really
iterating through this approach many
times both to improve each step and then
also to build capacity for of our
partners and other local groups so that
as the adaptive management occurs and
this plan is hopefully ratified
implemented and then eventually revised
through time that we at NOC have aren't
needed to do this process and then using
these outputs and really linking them
with actionable items in the plan and so
if we go back to that original question
we asked where should we cite coastal
notion uses to reduce risk during
ecosystem and and enhance the benefits
they provide to people that the results
of that to that question and to and
really the management question or mat so
we're these different activities can
occur and the image and you can find the
coastal zone management plan online and
you can see sort of how we link some of
these maps with different
recommendations and so just in summary
sort of these are the lessons that came
out of Mary buckles houses paper that I
mentioned early on ecological economics
looking across a lot of our different
applications but that simple models can
be useful in diverse decisions that
iterative science policy process really
matters for building capacity and for
improving results that accessible tools
and trained partners and capacity
building are critical that a wide
variety of metrics resonate so it was
really helpful to have both the
biophysical and the economic metrics
both because they're going to resonate
with different stakeholder groups but
also because it can tell you different
things if you look just at the
biophysical I didn't get into this too
much but if you look just at the
biophysical results for coastal
protection for example you're going to
get a different result than if you look
at the economic ones which combine both
value of developed and underdeveloped
land as well as a physical part of the
model it's important to get people into
the equation more explicitly so our
models have a lot of sort of the
biophysical component of them but it
gets trickier when you start to add in
some of the social and economic pieces
and we're still working on things like
under
standing how perceptions of different
kinds of activities like for example
using green infrastructure and coastal
hazard planning could influence and the
value and the utility of the service
information and then also this idea that
tailored tools will help take our
approach to scale so we've kind of found
that we can one of the things that's
really exciting about these ecosystem
service models is we can use them in a
lot of different decision context as I
showed on you know much earlier in the
presentation on that map of all the
different disk is decision contexts
around the world but the the models the
tools are sort of just one step in this
much larger process there's a lot that
we've learned at NAT cap about how to
use those within these on the ground
planning processes that are hard to
package up in a tool and so if there's a
way to kind of tailor these these are
these approaches for these different
decision contacts more sort of our hope
is that that the of Tape will be greater
so for example one of the things we're
doing right now is we're developing what
we call our marine spatial planning
concierge and that should be online and
available in the next few months that
really goes through the six step
approach that um that we've really
crystallized in our work in Belize and
talks about the important components of
each step and then makes information
available as well as sort of tailored um
computer code modeling code and and kind
of using this porthole as a way for
people to apply the models but with sort
of the guidance on how to pre-process
the data and guidance on how to
synthesize it and kind of examples of
work that we've done not only in Belize
and else but also elsewhere of how kind
of stakeholders and policymakers often
like to see these data these results
displayed they can be most useful for
for informing management and I think
this is my last slide I just
to share that from the next step of this
spatial planning work that we've been
doing is a new project in the Bahamas
with the Nature Conservancy and the
office of the prime minister in the
Bahamas and the work is funded by the
inter-american Development Bank and this
pilot project that we're going to be
doing to inform spatial planning on
Andros Island we hope and serve as an
example for a broader national economic
development an integrated coastal zone
planning process in the Bahamas and one
of the things that I find really
exciting it about this next project is
that we're thinking about how to build
implementation in from the start and so
that's one of the things that's
challenging is you can go through a
really comprehensive kind of a forward
thinking process like we did in Belize
but then there's all the implementation
that must still be done and so if
there's a way to have these planning
processes identify projects that are
going to be most fruitful and then
through loans to the to the government
there's the possibility to sort of
provide funding and kind of mark that
implementation is the important next
step from the from the start that we
think that it can be even more effective
for kind of seeing these planning
processes through so that's just
starting and we'll be going over the
course of the fog coming year and with
oh this is my last slide here now so I
just wanted to leave you with some
opportunities that I see to advance the
science and the practice of ecosystem
services especially in related to
coastal and marine systems so I think
one of the things that's really
important is to the build this body of
evidence and really to test this
assumption that services quantifying and
mapping services are going to help us do
a better job of exciting activities and
we need to build a larger body of
evidence and really look at how and
moderate monitor the outcomes to really
figure out whether or not we've
influenced decision making
I think there's some sort of service
specific advancements that can be made
across all of these different services
that I talked about but kind of in a
biophysical realm for example for
coastal protection one of the things
we're thinking about is head of multiple
habit type type types together so coral
reefs and mangrove forests how do they
complement each other and operate
together to reduce risk from disasters
they have different structures and
they're going to influence the sort of
movement of waves to the water in
different ways and so kind of digging
into these more complex mechanisms a
little bit more will help us understand
how do we need to restore conserve these
ecosystems sort of what order do we need
to do that in if we're thinking about
these different habitat types and then
on the social science and kind of
economic side questions like how does
variation and perceptions of risk
variation and demographics or
infrastructure value influence the
effectiveness of incorporating these
ecosystems into coastal defense planning
and there's those kinds of questions
across all of these different services
so getting more into the livelihoods
aspect of Fisheries and sort of
preferences aspect of tourists are all
sort of exciting next steps so I just
wanted to acknowledge that there's quite
a lot of work that's gone into this
project across a whole bunch of
different sort of disciplines and
institutions and I'd be happy to take
any questions Katie thank you very much
for your presentation we have some
questions from the audience and
colleagues that we would appreciate your
input on first of all during the
development of the coastal zone
management plan continued and increased
pressure on coastal development have
presented new challenges in Yukon in
countries like Belize development
challenges escalate at a pace that
policy development is often unable to
keep up with so how do you address this
challenge at natural the natural capital
project and with partners employees yeah
yeah that's a good point i mean i think
that's one of the reasons why sort of
expecting this iterative process from
the start
is wise to do so for example during our
work our three years of work there there
are several referendums around oil and
gas that were going through the sort of
government and stakeholder engagement
process and so we were able to include
that in that last scenario that we said
had gone out to a public review and but
of course you know even since that plan
has been designed there's now another
push to open certain areas for oil and
gas so I think some of it is expecting
that iteration some of it is sort of
putting an adaptive management policy in
place another aspect that I think we can
do more of that I really be excited to
work on a little bit more is thinking
about some of the scenarios in terms of
how can we create the most adaptive
system for some of these pressures that
development pressures for example but it
also be climate or you know completely
exterior sort of pressures so that we're
kind of designing scenarios that have
the greatest potential to be able to
adapt to those and it sort of be
resilient to those those future fluxes I
guess so we haven't done it you know as
much of that we're just starting to sort
of think about how to I think one of the
things we did really well and Belize is
really incorporating stakeholder and
local visions and I think one of the
things we can do also as scientists that
are collaborators in these processes
sort of bring these exterior pressures
that we may or may not be able to
anticipate into those scenarios and I
count from them for them as much as
possible from the beginning great thank
you we have a quest some questions from
cecilia from the audience so see we
would like to know the approximate
discount rate considered in the beliefs
project to obtain the net present value
furthermore she wants to know more about
the recommendable formula used to
calculate the carbon sequestration of
the mangroves and whether or not this
value can be used as an ecosystem
service um yeah okay well I think I so
we didn't do carbon storage and
sequestration in that integrated coastal
zone planning process so I didn't show
any results today for carbon stored in
sequestration we actually did it as part
of a kind of follow-on project for
climate adaptation Foreman climate
adaptation just in the placencia central
southern region um and so I have to go
back quite honestly I don't know that
off the top of my head a lot to go back
to that other report and check that out
for you I believe it might have been a
three percent but it might have been a
five I just I can't remember so one of
the things really think about with your
discount rate is kind of how secure the
sort of policy context is and into the
future and so how much is what you do
now going to likely be expected in the
future conditions um so it'd be happy
cecilia if you want to email me and we
can go back and forth on a little more
detail both about discount rates and
about carbon storage and sequestration
i'll just say that in the belize work we
they wanted to know for a single year
2025 was a time horizon so we weren't
too we weren't reporting accumulated
values over the whole 15 years so
there's some nuances there that I'd be
happy to get into more detail about over
email or follow up conversation great
Andrew from the audience is interested
in knowing more about the uncertainty of
your by physical models and he notes
that some of the results show up
with benefits and costs that are quite
similar and he was wondering if
different uncertainties for the
management options affect the comparison
and the policy recommendations yeah
that's a great question um so we did not
go through for all of the models and
then and look at a distribution of
values for each one of the parameters
we've done that for models separately so
and sort of outside of the specific
beliefs planning process so for example
we have a sense for like the coastal
protection model that the coefficient
the friction coefficient which is
something that is really hard to get a
standard value for you almost always
need an empirical value for it it ends
up being almost like a calibration
coefficient we know it does have a
pretty large influence on model results
so I think you know that would be that's
a really important question that I would
love to go back through some of these
analyses and try to figure out we have
to sort of balance this this challenge
of meeting our policy deadlines with
wanting to do the best available science
that we can do so with a lot of these
models what we've done is just fine in
the published papers we've compared
results to empirical data and try to get
a sense of how well in a model how well
is the sort of model structure likely
performing and then we're doing more and
more kind of uncertainty analyses within
policy processes but for this project
which was back now several years from
twenty ten to twenty thirteen a lot of
these models were in development as we
were doing it so I think it would be a
nice rest retrospective analysis to do
anybody out there looking for a PhD
thesis um you know there's a lot to do
with this with this work and
uncertainties one of them great thank
you
and our last question comes from Chelsea
from the audience and she asks how did
you make the decisions when combining
stakeholder input on future scenarios to
use a decision framework to rank or rate
different users or alternatives or goals
yeah that's a good question too um I
think you could do it in a much more
systematic way than we did it but I
think you know I think there's also the
importance of just getting the sort of
information down on paper and that was
really I think what we did well a lot of
times people and stakeholders get really
stuck at this sort of scenario step if
they can have endless conversations
about what they want for the future but
actually getting those down into maps
that then create data that we can run
through models is really really really
hard and so I have to commend our
partners in the coastal zone management
met office already in Institute for
really listening to what the
stakeholders and all in there in
different planning regions were saying
working with them to sort of sketch down
on paper where they imagine where
different things are happening now and
where they imagine having them I'm
happening in the future and then
creating making those into two spatial
maps and so so really that's why we have
the sort of conservation heavy scenario
and development heavy scenario was that
the visions that were on that sort of
development heavy side or included in
that scenario the ones that were on the
conservation side were included in that
scenario and then in terms of where
there are conflicts for that first
iteration of the informed management
scenario we did create this sort of
framework in table where we looked at
conflicts and compatibilities and so if
multiple activities could occur in the
same place which can often happen in the
ocean you know you really can have
sometimes fishing in the same place that
you'd have tourism if that could happen
even if you wouldn't want it to you know
you could say you'd rather have a marine
protected area for your tour of them but
if you could have multiple acts
tivities then in the in the development
scenario we allowed those multiple
activities it kind of ended up evolving
as sort of this ad hoc management and
then for that informs inerrant scenario
as I've said what we did was we used the
models to identify which areas habitats
we're receiving a lots of pressure and
then look to see which of the activities
were causing the greatest potential risk
and then we threw our stakeholder
engagement knew that coastal development
was something that was supported more by
more of these sort of coastal planning
bodies than oil and gas or or even
aquaculture there are several sort of
activities that were supporting more
than others and so then we went with the
kind of a cold or preference so the
combination of which activities are
proposing the most risk and on what is
the stakeholder preference great I think
no you could get into a lot more you
could develop using the approach we did
you can develop something even more
systematic sounds great thank you so
much that concludes the talk on models
of ecosystem valuation once again we
would like to thank Katie arkema for
joining us today if you wish to view a
recording of this webinar please visit
the gale centre for business and
environment website or access the
recording through the Yale iTunes
University podcast thank you for joining
us until next time this is andrew wu
from the yale center for business and
the environment